scientists can switch on cells in this
mouse's brain simply by switching on a
light the light activates nerve cells
which make the animal walk in circles
this neat trick is also a powerful new
tool using light to control the behavior
of cells is teaching us about everything
from how we wake up to how we learn
this is opto genetics
it all started with algae in 2002
researchers discovered that a protein
that causes green algae to swim towards
or away from light is a light-sensitive
Channel blue light causes the channel to
open and positive ions then flood into
the cell much like the influx of ions
that cause nerve cells to fire
neuroscientists were quick to see the
potential of these algal proteins they
realized that if they could get proteins
called channelrhodopsins to work in
mammalian nerve cells that have a very
precise way of controlling nerve
activity in the brain for many
applications this method would be better
than drugs which act too slowly and
better than electrical stimulation of
the brain which is less precise getting
an algal protein into for example a
mouse brain requires a bit of genetic
engineering first you take the gene that
encodes the protein plus another piece
of DNA called a promoter and you put
them in a virus when the virus is
injected into the mouse's brain it
infects neurons and delivers the gene a
chosen subset of those neurons will have
the right machinery to activate the
promoter and in those cells the algal
protein is expressed in the cell
membrane to activate the protein all you
need is light delivered via a
fiber-optic cable it's the ability to
target specific neurons in living moving
animals that makes this technique so
powerful and channelrhodopsins are not
the only proteins in the opto genetics
toolkit in this fly a different
light-sensitive system is used to target
just two out of 200,000 neurons these
neurons govern an escape response the
reflex that makes the fly flee as you
move in to swat it here a flash of light
activates the neurons making the fly
jump and spread its wings it can't take
off because it's trapped in a petri dish
as well as activating neurons with light
scientists wanted to be able to silence
them
switching neurons off is just a case of
using a different light-sensitive
protein such as hallow rhodopsin and a
different color of light watch how this
worms workout is interrupted when a
yellow light is switched on the light
activates hallo read opsin triggering a
flood of negative ions which inhibit the
worms motor neurons and stop it swimming
and neuro scientists aren't the only
ones using optogenetics
as well as turning neurons on or off a
diversity of tools allow researchers to
control many different processes in
living animals and in cells in dishes
these mouse heart cells have been
engineered to beat in time to pulses of
light
and here a light-sensitive protein makes
this skin cell move towards a laser
the applications are endless researchers
have already used light to transform the
stumbling of rats with Parkinson's
disease into a steady walk and show
which nerve cells fire when a sleeping
Mouse wakes optogenetics is shining
light on everything from animal behavior
to the interactions of proteins inside
cells
that's why Nature Methods has selected
opto genetics as its method of the year
2010
you